what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here we are going to watch
today why are you making noise in the
middle of my intro new rock stars what
if the zombie episode yeah
excited to check it out if there's one
thing i know these guys for doing mr
voss man is exceptional at enhancing an
appreciation for each and every episode
here and as we were watching i was like
there's so many easter eggs
way too much this is flying away past my
head and i only caught a few guys let's
see what's going on if you haven't
subscribed to new rockstars they're
becoming the biggest reaction channel
for all movies right now let's get into
it
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel
studios what if episode 5 what if
zombies which allows us to laugh through
a zombie apocalypse until we remember
that earlier apocalypse we were worried
about i'm gonna break down all the
easter eggs and animation details that
you might have missed from this episode
here we go we open with hulk blasting
back to earth via the bifrost in
avengers infinity war the framing
actually matches those shots including
the tilt rotation on the shot of
manhattan and the reflection of hulk in
the sanctum window but this time the
bifrost blast to the staircase comes not
as strange and wong are there but
leaving banner all alone
[Music]
uh
hello
no one except for the cloak of
levitation who might be earth's sole
survivor by the end of all this but no
word on what happened to wanda maximoff
and hulk kolku's skin is supposed to be
impenetrable or to bucky or how thor
would have held up or groot who as a
flora colossus is made of bark-like
cellulose instead of skin tissue and
blood i'm just saying we need a marvel
zombies part two and get this yes escape
automatically like right away like even
our discussion we were like wow this
should we could make a whole movie idea
about the whole anthology series out of
this i would love for marvel to actually
do even if it's just a direct movie for
you know streaming purposes or whatever
that would be
awesome i would love a marvel zombies
for streaming
maybe not for disney plus uh like i know
a lot of people a lot of people this is
like their favorite episode but if they
can push the envelope just a little bit
more with gore and horror that would be
cool like maybe on hulu or something you
know yeah
where all the edgier stuff goes yes the
cloak hooks up banner with the maroon
robes that sorcerers typically wear and
he asks was i too late
he's assuming that thanos already
succeeded in snapping away life i guess
he wouldn't know how long he was out for
ebony ma and call obsidian beam down to
the street without the heavy gusts of
their q-ship hulk refuses to come out as
he does during this scene infinity war
actually in that movie ebony mob
proclaims hear me
and rejoice you are about to die at the
hands of the children of thanos here it
plays out this way hear me and rejoice
come on come on
what do you mean now
you are about to die at the hands of the
children of yeah mixing in banners later
moment from infinity war come on come on
come on
[Music]
what do you mean no and right as ebony
moss says hands iron man's hand appears
and ma is cut off right before he says
thanos avoiding reminding us of the guy
to set up the final twist of the episode
banner's three co-warriors from infinity
war arrived
tony with alan silvestri's avengers
music there the silhouettes of wong and
iron man and doctor strange look haggard
and tattered tony is wearing his mark 50
nanotech armor from infinity war but
notice how his helmet is retracted the
better to bite us with banner says oh
boy are you guys screwed which banner
says later infinity war when thor
arrives late
you guys are so screwed
through the dust cloud you can make out
a super tattered zombie strange jumping
through a portal directly at ebony
no care whatsoever if ma were to take
the time stone in the eye of agamotto
they mask this brawl with thicker dust
in a lens flare and they use sound
effects in obsidian's hand to hint at
the violence that sort of seems like
overkill notice how the zombies can
still use their weaponry in their
sorcery in robert kirkman's marvel
zombies comics the virus known as the
hunger leaves the infected's full mental
capacity unaffected it just really
leaves him with a carnivorous drive akin
to zombies the comics also follow the
fantastic four magneto galactus a whole
bunch of characters as the virus spreads
to alternate realities and we learned
that the outbreak began when a watcher
from the earth z dimension sent a
zombified sentry to earth 2149 so yes a
watcher was behind all of this there you
go there's your movie right there or
your follow-up to another episode
i mean they could do one every season
they could do one every season or they
wanted to follow this up directly
because in the last episode the watcher
really became a character and got
involved sort of talking to doctor
strange he didn't like get involved in
changing but at least communicated with
doctor strange and then here he he's
just back in the shadows observing again
yeah yeah because he sent the first song
don't confuse me with that other guy i
would love that especially capture more
that grit that robert kirkman is able to
provide mr walking dead right there
because i was thinking for like a zombie
show i thought like oh you know what
i've really just rung a little bit more
tension if banner shows up at the sink
to santorum and then he's like walking
around you just stay with him and he's
isolated and it's around he just grabs
that cloth clothing he walks around the
city for a little bit maybe like 28 days
later that's what i mean yeah like how
much more attention that would have
brought absolutely our watcher doesn't
intervene and it's caused by something
else that i'll get to later notice how
zombie stark's face is decayed but his
earlobe still has a bit of flesh tone in
there kind of like how we see with
zombie cap's ear later showing how this
virus is really just affecting their
limbic systems in their brains and the
right mind stone frequency this could be
reversed but to a pretty decayed bony
body and what kind of quality of life
are we talking there long gnaws on
obsidian severed arm similar to how he
uses a portal to sever that arm in
infinity war but then wong here dies a
similar way portal severance this time
to the head banner kicks it just like
how he kicked obsidian's arm all freaked
out wasp using his sword
to disintegrate these zombies who are
you all that's left he has some fun word
play from hope there hope is all that's
left the dad jokes aren't limited to
scott here spider-man scoops up banner
relax i'm just your friendly
neighborhood spider-man oh yeah well
then what the hell happened to the
neighborhood yeah peter burger is voiced
not by tom holland but by actor and
singer hudson teams notice how his suit
isn't exactly like the one we saw in
infinity war perhaps because sony might
own that exact movement oh gosh
the disney owned version of the suit
that they made for the disney parks yeah
i think that might actually help out a
little bit with not having to associate
or make it easier to not think about tom
holland because sometimes i'm distracted
when i'm like that's clearly not you
know the actor they're supposed to be
playing this time around i really wasn't
distracted maybe because i'm so used to
many different iterations of spider-man
both in live action and animated i don't
know something about where i i really
like the choice of doing a completely
different suit for this one versus the
one in infinity war there's something
about it i personally am more gravitated
towards and i think a lot of people are
oh and another thing i'll add on too
that just makes it more exciting when
you go to the disney parks and then you
see that spider-man suit and then you're
like hey hey that's the one that's the
one in your disney show it's actually
canon now the watcher says like too many
great catastrophes this one sprang from
a place of love
and hope yeah notice how he's much
closer to us than he usually is and now
we see his mouth as he's talking like
ever since nearly interfering last
episode he is getting nearer and nearer
each week as he takes a less godly and
more personified form he explains how
two weeks earlier hank pym went to
rescue janet van dyne from the quantum
realm notice how pym approaches a
crystalline barrier which in ant-man the
wasp represented the barrier between
subatomic space and the separate
dimension that the quantum realm is but
here the distant orange light the
tendrils the floating crags are all on
this side of the barrier and he lands on
a different surface than before and
there is a problem janet van dyne
contracted a quantum virus that
corrupted her brain
yeah so the watcher doesn't go into any
further detail about the origins of this
quantum virus or why janet hank didn't
get affected when in the quantum realm
in the movie which is a bit weird
because every episode up until now we
see at least some kind of deliberate
turning point from the movements that
characters make whether it's peggy
carter deciding to stay in the room or
doctor strange still being in a
relationship with christine palmer so
what is the difference here well after
staring at this for too long notice
these purple pillars of light that now
beam up from below those were not in the
movie i'm wondering if these could be
the virus
i speculated that janet could have been
intentionally infected by someone who
engineered this virus specifically to
get to thanos maybe even engineered by
the celestials known to be experimental
biological engineers of the marvel
universe hoping perhaps that zombie
thanos might use his stones instead to
incarnate a sudden influx of life
because what do zombies want more than
anything an unlimited amount of
uninfected flesh to chew on and that
this might trigger that emergence that
in the eternal trailer they said hulk's
snap energy surge triggered do you guys
realize eric voss has just been pitching
the follow-up episode for marvel zombies
the whole time i think you've earned the
writing credit by now it makes it more
interesting i think in any zombie movie
or show a lot of times you don't get a
full explanation as to what really
caused this you know you usually get
hints or alluding to like right here you
picked up on that special specific
purple particle area that's about as big
of a clue as you'll get but if she's
isolated he shows up when she's already
been turned it makes sense why you
wouldn't get an explanation right then
in there
yeah exactly you know where you're going
with this i don't know if it's that far
uh you know what's celestials and all
that involvement but damn how cool would
that be for type this man should write
this man should be a writer it's only a
matter of time don't forget us when
you're at the top vos meanwhile there's
no sighting of the mysterious quantum
realm city that was hidden in the
background and ant-man of the wasp which
i now believe to be kang's kingdom of
chronopolis since kang is returning
ant-man of waspanomania there's also an
argument that kang could have released
this virus as a way to try to
biologically subvert the absolute point
of thanos's snap on the timeline i'm
just saying the fact that the virus
didn't affect these characters and
ant-man
something changed someone wanted this
virus to get into our reality meanwhile
you got to love the watchers sass here
that happened
and that shadow crosses over hank's
lifeless hand leading hope to greet what
she thinks is her mom and i love scott
piping in the background there mom hi
miss van dyke hank attacks scott and
scott's hand grasp the glass in the
classic horror frame or like roses sex
grasping titanic
[Music]
the avengers quinjet lands on golden
gate bridge with hawkeye infinity war
era blonde natasha catback and a civil
war suit with his shield that has
already been resurfaced after t'challa
scratched it in civil war and his 2018
beard shaved supposedly this crisis must
have ended the feud between him and tony
and then of course iron man and black
panther i love this lineup i would love
to see these guys in action but notice
as the camera pulls away we see the
zombies tackle iron man and hawkeye and
natasha but none actually tackle
t'challa in fact the last we see of him
through that crowd he is swatting back
one of those zombies and in that tight
vibranium weave it makes sense that he
would be able to repel the bites on to
peterborough
spiderman homecoming it's also similar
to the rules in the movie zombieland we
see peter here with other survivors
including happy hogan shirt reading i'm
not single i'm saving myself for thor
skills driving coffee and boxing we're
calling his past memories he's an
amateur wrestler and his fireman
he wears tony stark's wristwatch based
palm repulsor from civil war this would
be one of the previous versions stark
would have after he upgraded to the mark
50. then kurt david desmalcheon's
character from the ant-man films he's
wearing his ex-con security jacket
skills languages slavic folklore and
crime slavic folklore referring to his
baba yaga ghost story that comes back
later this episode david dusk mulching
man he is just killing it polka dot man
he's in the bat in one of those batman
animated movies things a long halloween
yeah
he's got his own comic book that he's
writing now and now he's in what if he's
already been the comic book connoisseur
and then so i was so happy to see that
he's here because you would think they
might go with like luis or something
like that yeah yeah but instead they go
with a curtain nah man
michael pena after tom and jerry they're
like oh we got to move on to david
dodd's function because we can't do ti
so
but i also think this guy looks nothing
like david dust mulch in this animation
yeah that's the one thing is this could
have just been any
white guy he has such like distinct
features that i was like i feel like you
could have yeah i feel like you could
have tailored his face especially more
bucky barnes showers in a usa themed
shower curtain as he later i didn't even
notice that
he's listed as silent but deadly skills
murder killer arm heavy sleeper of
course referring to his deep freeze
hibernation bucky has the new black
vibranium arm that was given to him in
infinity war so the wakandans must have
given him this arm as this zombie
outbreak began he says you know all i
have to do is squeeze right okay kind of
like indiana jones's threat to that nazi
woman in the last crusade
all i have to do is squeeze then sharon
carter listens the blonde bond skills
spycraft first aid eulogies referring to
how she patched up team cap and
eulogized peggy carter in civil war and
final member of the team okoye who's in
the u.s looking for t'challa after he
went missing we see how their base is a
series of subway cars and a bus and then
a school bus oh they're
supported between buildings a pretty
genius idea for a sanctuary and a zombie
apocalypse i'm not sure how they were
able to avoid falcon all this time they
use what looks like a stark's gauntlet
from the hulkbuster armor to hollow
project the signal that they've received
it also looks like they got a super
nintendo over on the right banner says
we'll write him details that location
look familiar agent carter it's camp
lehigh in new jersey camp lehigh of
course where kat first trained in the
first movie and where he and tony stole
the tesseract in end game in 1970 and
where cap and natasha discovered zola's
algorithm in winter soldier leading that
place getting bombed back in 2014 though
most of it appears intact this episode
happy drives them to grand central i
thought you were an uber driver no no
i'm a personal chauffeur there's a
difference
yeah we realized that they are in the
pymtech band that hope drove in ant-man
and wasp with this jump scare evoking
that huge pigeon and they use it to
burst through the zombie's head now
grand central station is where hulk
punched thor out of the movie and the
prologue of spider-man homecoming but
this station does not connect to new
jersey anyway they split up splitting up
do you guys just not have horror movies
in wakanda we don't need them we have
american reality shows yeah peter brings
up a crucial point in most zombie
fiction that a lot of the times
characters are not as aware of horror
movie tropes as the audiences a meta
concept explored really well in movies
like scream and cabin in the woods
starring thor but in this case peter
parker is aware of zombie movies
everyone else is not and in one of
vision they did screen george a romero's
night of living dead so characters in
this universe should be aware of some of
these tropes all right guys look i know
this is a bit of a nitpick okay because
i enjoyed the meta commentary pretty
much 99 of the time it's just that it
did
kind of pull me out slightly i started
just thinking to myself okay that's
funny but that's also a good point yeah
if the zombie movies and all that exist
everything is essentially zombies you'd
think earth's mightiest heroes
everyone else would know like okay all
right we gotta have an idea of what to
handle here but only this one guy
because he's a kid yeah he's all this
i'm like sorry he's been around since
way before peter parker was even bored
you know well i mean imagine how fun
that could have been like okay kid what
do you know about zombies tell us
everything yeah you know and then you
can get even more fun movie references
and stuff but yeah it is like he does
seem like the one person who kind of
gets the situation it's a nitpick i know
it was just uh it was kind of thing of
again it's self-aware but i still feel
like it needs to be feel like we're
self-aware now who knows
now that you've acknowledged this don't
just stop at the knowledge but use it
happy uses his palm repulsor
but he and sharon get attacked by zombie
hawkeye and after happy dies his zombie
self still says blam
meanwhile zombie falcon attacks bucky
and okoye and okoye splits them in half
the kind of kill deny gurira's other
zombie killing character michonne would
deliver in the walking dead that was
your friend sorry about that i should be
sad but i'm not yeah this is before
bucky and sam worked together in the
balkan the winter soldier when they
still had more of a love-hate
relationship coming out of civil war can
you move
no you couldn't have done that earlier i
hate you they're able to escape the
train station and spider-man gets the
help from the cloak of levitation it's a
good look on you really you think i
could pull it off maybe i'll grow into
it maybe a hint toward peter's coming
experience with sorcery and spider-man
no way home meanwhile zombie cat kills
sharon notice as she's at his feet her
finger twitches a little back to life
zombie cap's sleeve is torn you can see
he still has a defined deltoid my boy's
still jacked or it's like a bloody gash
either way he's cut notice that bucky
punches zombie cap in that jaw
plunged down a plus dad joke cap tosses
his shield at bucky who hurls it back
similar to bucky's shield catch and
winter soldier and it cuts them in half
sorry pal
i guess this is the end of the line
yeah end of the line was their repeated
line to each other all right let's break
down some rules here so i get there
they've got some deteriorating flesh but
they also seem to still possess their
powers enough capability to use their
powers would their body still physically
be weak enough to slice a body in half
that's an excellent question
because yeah they certainly seem
powerful the shields hit a lot of people
in these movies that no one's cut in
half yeah yeah yeah what's the rules
around the physique of the body at this
point and i know that you know again a
lot of powers are accounted for by your
biology but i got to feel like if your
skin was rotting some of these powers
would destroy the host body exactly
what are the rules
not exactly criticizing i'm questioning
though also you'll notice the music
there was actually a dark minor chord
version of captain america's theme
[Music]
sorry pal
i guess this is the end of the line
you see there's something about that
line there that i i think would have
just made a little extra oomph for me
because already this video is already
doing plenty to make me appreciate this
episode so much more like i love all the
details and and there's so much more
references that i didn't even pick up on
in the moment but i think that delivery
if that was played a little bit more
like somber yeah like he's actually
affected or sad except it was kind of
like
merry christmas [ __ ] it was like
a yippy kaiye delivery versus
like sorry cap this is the end of the
one you know yeah it's like a badass
quip rather than an actual like
lamentation to his best friend yeah
pope asks peter how he stays so upbeat
my mom dad uncle ben mr stark now happy
i've lost a lot but my aunt may says he
used to say that if we don't keep
smiling when they can't then we might as
well just be gone too yes this is our
first official mention of uncle ben in
the mcu after his initials appeared on
peter's luggage and far from home it
could have been any bfp franklin parker
not big parker pope carries them over
the zombie horde by growing big though
with that tear in her suit and how she's
able to stay large even after her helmet
visor is cracked this would be the first
time the mcu has shown pimtech powered
characters of different sizes outside of
the closed system of their suits
something that the comics don't really
worry about and i guess this episode
doesn't really either vision explains
how he was able to repeal the zombies
the mind stone it emits a sub-frequency
that is not to their liking could that
mean the infection is some kind of
encephalopathy yeah encephalopathy it
means damage to the brain meanwhile this
bunker looks like the one cap and
natasha found zola's ai-n in the winter
soldier but must be a different one than
the one that imploded now remember the
milestone carried
spoke to vision to warn him about thanos
coming in infinity war and this could
have been linked to the plan i've
suggested that this virus could have
been engineered to get to thanos via
specifically the mine stone a stone that
i believe the celestials first gave the
thanos before loki's invasion since we
know the celestials did used to wield
infinity stones and all this is about
getting that stone back to zombie thanos
in this case because why else would
thanos go to wakanda looking for the
mine stone if the mine stone wasn't
there yet unless it's uh some kind of a
oversight
[Laughter]
[Music]
i love how that moment with thanos has
raised so many questions it's as cool of
a visual as it is it did bring up a lot
of like why would he go to the mine
stone wasn't there but that's why he
went through an infinity war right yeah
taking place around that time yeah and i
feel like with the amount of stones that
he had collected at that point
he would have been able to prevent
himself from getting bitten i feel like
he was but they all had their powers so
i'm sure they could land a hit on them
but he couldn't just like reverse time
you would think
[Laughter]
you would think i don't know i mean i'm
starting to get to a point where i'm
like any plot hole i guess could just be
explained by it's a different timeline
maybe different events unfolded to get
us here but the thados one it was a it
was a really cool visual uh awesome
cliffhanger but then it also did open
the door for
wait a minute
asking questions here yeah
vision saves scott lang's head in the
glass jar futurama style and okoye tells
him
don't cry you'll fog up your jaw sorry
yeah tula tula is a traditional zulu
lullaby in order to stop babies from
crying they realize vision blurred them
there
tala has lost a leg similar to how he
does in the marvel zombies comics and
vision says while your anger is
predictable i can assure you my actions
though unsavory were nevertheless born
of logic i still cannot entirely fathom
what i have done but i cannot bring
myself to leave her sounds like vision
found it logical to contain wanda rather
than unleash her on the world though it
also sounds like loving wanda is just
something in his code which i think is
pretty beautiful but also really messed
up how he like chopped up people it's so
funny just how their love for each other
has led to the
abuse of so many individuals
people yes that have suffered
for their marital issues it didn't hit
me until i was working on the thumbnail
for uh the reaction i was like yeah
what's happening this vision guy died
hey man this is the worst one of all
though just by his own hand
geez she keeps dying wanda awakens her
terrifying baba yaga form at the far end
of the hallway now it's super creepy how
the shadows of her are cast both in
front of her on the floor and on the
wall behind yeah
thanks for the red dinosaurs behind her
it also suggests that some light is
catching an additional dark spirit that
must be standing behind her
the cloak of levitation scott making a
pretty fun duo between the two of them
yes of course the levitation spell from
harry potter and i don't think that or
any of these constitute dad jokes dad
jokes are really just solid word play
that gen z keeps moving the goal post on
because they're mad at everyone older
than them for ruining the planet which
fair okoye gets taken
solid take boss envision
the bunker saying there's a quest yet in
the hangar yeah quadjets are the
predecessors to quinjets a quadjet is
actually what carolyn fury piloted in
captain marvel and vision to atone
out the mind stone from his own head
creating the kind of shock wave that
happened when his mindset was destroyed
in infinity war but also the moment he
does his eyes roll over and he turns
grey just like he did in infinity war
and showed back up as in one division
banner wants to stay behind and let them
escape i don't think i can lose another
friend today so avenge us yes scott
t'challa are like
here dude we're not friends enough and
if you think about it peter wasn't
called an avenger until tony stark
knighted him in infinity war which never
happened here so banner telling him to
avenge them gives peter that promotion
that's neat that's cool i think that
would have just made that moment even
that much more powerful if we had just
like a scene earlier of like peter
parker talking about like oh i didn't
even become an avenger or something like
that yeah yeah yeah yeah that's why i'm
grateful for d rockstar because they
point out things like oh damn that
actually makes me love that moment even
more i feel like in the actual viewing
of it that would have hit that much
extra if we had a run time of an episode
that allowed us to feature a scene to
have a couple character scenes where
they discuss what life was like before
yeah so that way when he says that
you're like oh that's cool then i would
go remember tony night at him but now
it's
alex bruce banner finally forces hulk
out of hiding and he and wanted duke it
out but we never see what comes from
that or where bucky landed giant hope
tries to grab the jet and fails and
pissed chucks a zombie at them
t'challa tells peter in my culture
that is not the end they are still with
us as long as we do not forget them a
touching callback to chadwick boseman's
memorable words after t'chaka's death
and civil war in my culture dead it's
not the end it's more of a stepping off
point isn't that crazy how some of the
lines that he has been given
for
the episodes he's been in they just hit
so different now don't they if nobody
knew the circumstances up until his
passing like it's uncanny the way some
of these now to hear them are like
messages from a premonition of some kind
yeah yeah it is very it is very
interesting just how much more weight
now it holds and it just takes on this
other
worldly quality that most nothing vast
majority of us could did not anticipate
you know and it makes me really glad
they gave him some good freaking lines
yeah it's like damn yeah yeah
absolutely because he has been distinct
in both of these exactly sure yeah yet
as they arrive to wakanda inside the
shield gates zombies claw to get out
standing above zombie dora milaje and
jabari warriors zombie thanos stands
victorious five out of six stones in his
gauntlet notice how his pose matches his
final do it myself shot in the age of
ultron post credit scene now to think
about where thanos has been in this
timeline he must have gotten the reality
stone from nowhere in the soul stone
from vermeer meaning gamora is dead and
he had planned to rendezvous with ebony
ma on titan for the time stone but now
that ma never made that trip thanos
probably went directly to earth to
recover the eye of agamotto from new
york and i guess then headed to the only
place the surviving avengers would go or
maybe they just didn't think about this
the point is thor is still out there
somewhere along with root and rocket and
the guardians of the galaxy minus gamora
meaning there is more what if to what if
zombies to explore as zombie thanos
would probably go planet to planet now
and then maybe even to other timelines
by infecting the tva so marvel again
please give us a marvel zombies part two
keep us smiling for hope that's what i'm
talking about man he just he completed
the outline for the follow-up to marvel
topic just clip those little moments
throughout this breakdown and then
you'll have the treatment
for part two of marvel's outfit how
unique of a zombie movie would that be
if the people in charge of timelines are
infected by the zombies and then that
virus is spreading throughout the
universe stuff throughout the multiverse
like how insane would that be that that
would be just so nutty if they just did
like a season of just it just ends in
this
completely despairing way in this
singularity where every reality is
overrun with zombies there's nothing
else that would have been cool follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
thank you for putting all this together
you guys are hard at work lately man so
happy you guys exist i like that episode
a lot more now yes yeah
i always end up doing because there's
all those details that i know like when
you say details you missed on their
titles i'm like yeah
those details constantly enhance my
appreciation it's just that thing when
you further understand something the
easier it is to like it
it's
plain and simple that's why it does work
on me
all right guys well subscribe to new
rockstars you haven't done so already
you can subscribe to us keep a lookout
for our next what if reaction last but
not least
pandemic jones why would we not shout
out
pandemic jones
when we are watching the marvel pandemic
episode dealing with a case of osmosis
jones so that's the crossover we deserve
it's animated it ties in oh yeah
pandemic jones you are the greatest
threat to humanity and that's why i
respect you in order to operate in this
life we must feel fear and we must fear
whatever we answer to and pandemic jones
you are that fear that's how you rule
that's how you control people take us on
youtube always afraid of the youtube
overlords and you were most afraid to be
you i know that you have secrets on us
you can expose at any moment create a
pandemic about us oh it would be bad we
would lose
tens of subscribers at least ten yeah
pandemic i appreciate you being here and
you taught me a thing or two about fear
then in order to really connect with
people you must make them afraid of you
[Music]